[Musique]
c'est un ouvrage colossal 20 000 mètres
cubes d'eau sont ici stockés dans ce
réservoir ce bassin de rétention situé à
Dassy vient tout juste d'être inauguré
par le Département la saphir et les élus
de la région sud aujourd'hui je crois
que le bassin sud est un peu le le pool
de développement et le poumon du
développement économique du Sud de la
réunion de la Réunion tout simplement et
si on veut aussi que ces différents
activités viennent s'installer que le
développement se poursuit que
l'augmentation la population soit
accompagnée des besoins nécessaires au
quotidien une réserve d'eau stratégies
qui servira au développement des terres
agricoles irriguées à l'alimentation en
eau potable des ménages et aux besoins
des sites industriels le département
avec ces infrastructures poursuit ses
projets d'aménagement hydrauliques sur
le territoire à grande échelle avec le
basculement des eaux on irrigue toutes
les terres à travers d'acide le mais on
va continuer aussi à développer de
l'irrigation notamment dans l'est de
l'île pour les agriculteurs comme pour
les communes de l'Est et le projet
mérennes le gouvernement nous annoncé 30
millions d'euros quoi financer le projet
méren donc le mouvement de construction
des ouvrages pour ensuite ce nouveau
réservoir de d'assis capte l'eau de la
galerie connectée au barrage du Bras de
la Plaine une eau qui s'acheminera
ensuite vers les communes de
l'entre-deux Saint-Pierre le tampon
peut-il et saint Joseph
[Musique]